ده بالنسبه للبنان عين على الميدان واخرى
على حركه الموفدين الدبلوماسيين الى بيروت
وسناتر الخارجيه الفرنسي سيصل اليوم الى
بيروت بعد اختتام زيارته في تل ابيب على
المستوى الميداني اليوم نتحدث عن عمليتين
حتى الان وتاتي هذه العمليات ضمن الاطار
التقليدي الكلاسيكي الذي بتنا نعهده يوميا
ولكن حزب الله بات يستخدم بشكل واسع
النطاق الصواريخ التي تحمل رؤوسا من زنه
حربيه كبيره نتحدث عن صواريخ بركان التي
تم قصف اليوم سكنه هنين فيها وايضا اطلاق
صاروخ من نوع فلق واحد باتجاه موقع جل
الاعلام هذا الامر ياتي ضمن السياق العام
الذي كنا نشاهده منذ اشهر في محاوله من
حزب الله لاستمرار عملياته وتحويل الارض
هنا في جنوب لبنان وتحديدا عند هذا الخط
الحدودي الى معادله جديده تفرض اخلاء كامل
المستوطنين من الجهه المقابله من الحدود
اللبنانيه ضمن اطار ما يصفه بمعركه مسانده
قطاع غزه وبالتالي من هنا التقارير
الوارده من اسرائيل عن الاضرار الكبيره
التي لحقت بالمستوطنات يجري الحديث عن نحو
450 منزلا تم اصابتها بقبل الصواريخ التي
يطلقها حزب الله وذلك في محاوله لتثبيت
قاعده بان هذا الخط الحدودي سيبقى مشتعلا
طالما ان العدوان الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه
مستمر وبالتالي هذه العمليات وما رصدناه
اليوم سواء من ناحيه حزب الله او من خلال
الرد الفعل الاسرائيلي والغارات والقصف
الاسرائيلي لعدد كبير من البلدات
اللبنانيه وياتي استكمالا لما حصل بالامس
من خلال سلسله كبيره من الغارات كل ذلك
يصب ضمن نفس الاطار ونفس السياق على مستوى
حركه الدبلوماسيين لا يمكن فصله عن حركه
الميدان مياده هنا في لبنان لان وصول وزير
الخارجيه الفرنسي بعد ختام زيارته في تل
ابيب الجميع ينتظر ما هي الرسائل التي
سيحملها معه لا سما ان التحذيرات
والتهديدات الاسرائيليه تواكبت خلال
اليومين الماضيين مع لغه يمكن القول بانها
تحمل الشيء ونقيضه بمعنى انها تحذر من ان
الحرب مقبله على هذه الجبهه وبان اسرائيل
ستوسع خياراتها العسكريه هنا قوات
الاحتلال ستقوم بمهاجمه هذه المناطق ولكن
في الوقت عينه يجري الحديث عن سيناريو
الدبلوماسي وبالتالي اليوم هذه الزياره
لوزير الخارجيه الفرنسي تاتي ضمن سياق
متكامل من زيارات متعدده وزير خارجيه
بريطانيا قبلها اسبانيا ايطاليا وغيرها
كلهم حملوا الرسائل بضروره تطبيق القرار
1701 ولكن بعجاله مياده الموقف اللبناني
سواء كان الرسمي او من حزب الله يتقاطع
عند نقطه واحده تطبيق القرار 1901 ينبغي
ان يبدا من اسرائيل ووقف خروقاتها وهذا
الامر لا يمكن الحديث عنه والترتيبات عند
طول هذه الحدود ق قبل وقف العدوان
الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه وفقا ما تقول
الحكومه اللبنانيه وايضا حزب الله اها